what's going on guys so today we were
going to bring you an exciting anchorman
2 Christmas Spectacular I interviewed
the cast of anchorman and we got the
footage back and watched it we realized
that we blew it ill prepared each bit
worse than the last we could have buried
it and never let it seen the light of
day but no we decided to use it as a
learning experience in the spirit of
learning we give you how not to do a
junket Congrats on making an awesomely
funny movie so we're gonna put this
together it's gonna be like an
old-school Christmas special if you guys
would please be on my Christmas
Spectacular
sure yay tip number one don't walk in
there with the deadly combination of
having an overcomplicated bit and
looking like a off the street kai
um ask each of you gentlemen to just sit
on my lap and tell me your Christmas
wish I don't know if I don't I've got
okay bad sciatica tip number two your
first request shouldn't be for
inappropriate physical contact with
a-list actors can we do a little bit of
play-acting and take us back to the day
that Mary and Joseph tried to get into
that in but we're not gonna mock
Christianity right no okay you sure yes
okay yes you know what what if we do
I'll kill you just like at the
Thanksgiving dinner table don't bring up
religion ah you look big with child did
he look like
obi-wan Kenobi why would a man say that
about his wife no who would character
you don't ask them to participate in a
bit without explaining it first
oh I'm the innkeeper oh okay we're full
up tonight there's no vacancy
who's the force I want the ingredients
to make your famous cook holiday cookies
okay here's the thing I'll never do
again don't silently stare at christina
applegate while you mix crap in a bowl
for two minutes
creepy well you guys I'm gonna kill you
a tiny ornament on my tree sure when
you're coming up with your bits maybe
have a funny part or something that's
construed as a payoff and no Holiday
Spectacular well it was that little bit
that was it yeah was it yeah now let's
close it out well how is what was the
payoff seeing a tiny tree yeah okay
fellas home without gifts Oh
Mike this motorcycle rallies winter day
in the life of Macy Gray awesome oK
we've got a lot of don'ts here's a do do
give Will Ferrell a Macy Gray DVD it's
like the only thing that worked I can't
wait to watch this I feel terrible I
didn't get you a lap dance you know what
if David Koechner has to give you a lap
dance Salvage bit your interview has
gone off the rails joy to the world the
Lord
lastly if you're getting towards the end
of your interview and it's already been
very uncomfortable don't force them to
sing a hymn you know what I think people
are really gonna want to see anchormen
too when they watch this I think so I
really want to thank the cast of
anchorman 2 for putting up with my
ridiculous shenanigans and thank you for
not calling security to drag the weirdo
in the sweater out of the junket please
go see anchorman 2 it's in theaters now
very funny flick so what is your most
Awkward celebrity run-in let us know
your true story in the comment section
below or just make one up we won't know
the difference
best answer gonna get a screen junkies
t-shirt thank you for watching have a
Merry Christmas
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter by
bike